that's that's why we're alive because
when we are living we feel and when we
feel it it actually has some type of
meaning so let's for example say
something very mundane do you remember
what you ate this breakfast for
breakfast this morning
maybe not because it was just a regular
day do you remember let's say like it
was your graduation day
do you remember what you had for
breakfast maybe you didn't even eat
because you're so you were so you were
so nervous you're going on stage you're
going to get your you know so so
emotions is what makes things stick
you're not going to remember something
if it wasn't something exciting we don't
have the brain capacity to remember
everything so our brains are made to
process and really hone in on things
that they think is important so whether
that is Extreme happiness extreme Bliss
extreme ecstasy to The Other Extreme of
hurt rejection pain trauma those are the
things that we are going to always
remember so it doesn't matter if maybe
this girl actually had
100 really good encounters with guys but
she doesn't value them because maybe
she's numb to it and then all it takes
is that one time because maybe she's so
traumatized at one point of her life and
so when she does come across someone who
validates her her
um her perception which is that men are
bad then she just latches on and then
she gets very angry why don't men do the
same thing they do the same it's not a
gender it's not a gender thing because
men and women
one of them are different in the sense
that women are a lot more volatile and
they're a lot more outside when it comes
to expressing their emotions the problem
with men is that you do feel and I
actually think that men feel more but
they're probably about feeling more I'm
talking about men like women demonizing
men versus men demonizing women I'm just
curious do you guys feel like men and
women do it the same just going around
yes or no no no definitely not what
about no no what about you Ash
all right
sorry
um what was the question do you think
men and women demonize each other the
same no no can I actually say what I
actually think maybe why women I don't
know about the men but I think this is
why women are so
well why the feminists are so angry okay
um so
I'm gonna say Feminine energy because I
believe that we all have a little bit of
both and that's that's actually a good
thing to have we have both in us and
depending on the right situation you
will lean into one more than the other
uh I think you see it more in a girl
because I guess we're more encouraged to
be more masculine these days anyways now
I think when girls innately are female
feminine energy they do want to feel
cherished they want to be taken cared of
that is like the most pure basic feeling
to start with right now what
unfortunately happens is that
when girls start maturing so when they
start getting into teenage years when
they start getting awareness of you know
sexuality in themselves they also
unfortunately girls tend to mature
quicker than guys so they outperform
them sometimes at school they're more
quicker at focusing and honing into
growing up and being a little bit more
adulty whereas guys might take a little
bit longer and it just it is just what
it is guys just takes a little bit
longer and that's okay I think I agree
just because I think I agree with
majority of what you're saying but I
think the point that seems to get uh
missed out these days is that
your you have more feminine energy
that's because you're born that way we
have more masculine energy because we're
blown away I think the society now the
problem is to say we're trying to make
each other so similar even though we're
much similar than we're different we
need to appreciate the differences
between us so I don't think there's any
benefits to a man being feminine even
though this is what females are
requesting nowadays I want my guy to be
more in touch with the feminine so
there's actually no benefit to it
because as a man
you cry we I mean men cry it's not it's
not it's not like we don't cry but
he's crying in front of your girl and
see what happens she's not going to
respect you know I've heard policy
doesn't all pretends because it's true
women are actually requesting these days
like it's actually it's not going to
benefit them in a relationship you don't
want a weak man as soon as you as soon
as you see that your man is weak you're
going to go elsewhere so yeah I mean I
agree and and I I will I that's a very
valid point I agree with you as well and
I get where you're coming from I think
just to finish off my point so
what from what I said earlier girls then
get pushed if you can see what I'm
saying get pushed to become very
masculine because they feel like and
actually it's from personal experience
my own mother tells me to my they're
pushing us to go to college they're
pushing us to go into very masculine you
know type of Trades and in order to be
I'm in the medical field so in order to
be look if you're coming to see me do
you want me to be a woman who doesn't
know how to make decisions yeah no you
don't want that right real quick because
it's a very important distinction you
just made then I don't hear much women
say it's like you just said that your
mother encourages you to be more
masculine What I Hear nowadays is we as
we know on the Internet is men versus
women like we don't hear much of
examples of your mother encouragement we
hear men make us like this men make us
you've just been honest there and said
and do you think I'm gonna say it's true
I think that's a problem
that um women are making women become
more masculine yeah that's an issue um
but it's just just before I discovered
um
that's an important distinction it's not
the men that's doing that because we
want you to be feminine like men want
women to be feminine we don't want you
to be masculine we already gotta deal
with the dudes that I'm asking we don't
want to deal with a masculine female so
it's an issue I think I'm definitely
going to agree with you with that and
I'm going to get to the point you made
as well so what happens is that then the
girls are encouraged to stand up for
themselves don't wait around and rely on
the guy you've got to be self-sufficient
by the way that's a good thing because
you actually if if you're going into a
relationship you want a partnership you
would want so this is how it works so if
you ever seen 300 have you why would you
why would you want a partnership when
that's not how it's worked for all of
history what I meant by partnership I'll
explain a little bit okay
in 300 Leonidas is the king and he has
his Queen
when
when someone comes to his doorstep and
threatens him literally threatens his
his whole livelihood of his people
with literally cutting people's heads
off walking up to him and showing
violence
his Queen stepped up and said
this is not okay
and the messenger was turning around and
saying how dare you as a woman speak
and in the end when Leonidas then
before he kicked them down the well
he actually said you disrespected my
queen and actually what she said as well
is she said like only Spartan women can
give birth to Spartan men which is
strong men so what is beautiful about
that relationship is that they are not
equal in the sense that they don't have
the same energy but
we can agree that they're both strong in
different ways that's not a partnership
because he needs okay so what I meant is
I'm not saying you're eating she needs
him more than he needs her so what I'm
saying is I'm not saying that they're
equal and that they give the same thing
in but what they do is that they
complement each other and support each
other and the beautiful thing about that
relationship is that she's actually very
accomplished so he feels safe walking
away and going into war potentially
never coming back but he knows that his
wife is strong so she can